[Musique]
drapeau c'est cool clair si elles
avaient déjà en plus sur moi j'aime bien
me faire du mal je suis mais quelque
part du mal mais moi je suis sidéré
voilà j'ai voulu aller voir un jour de
travail pour montrer leur passion du mec
un peu la main suivante je pense qu'à la
fin parce que jamais j'aurais imaginé
que je pouvais pas imaginer parce que ça
qu'elle vienne tard comme sarah qu'elles
se déplacent qu'elle vienne me voir je
c'est impossible à imaginer je sais même
pas comment vous faites pour l'année à
venir quoi des super et mais je suis
content je suis content parce que tu
crois que ça lui a fait plaisir de venir
et d'émotion parce que l'on retrouve
toute l'équipe tout seul et qui fait
passer 70 quand même tous les jours par
des multicoques toujours et donc un tour
beaucoup d'émotion il y avait des fleurs
et des chocolats et laisser les
chocolats c'est comme si l'adversaire ne
sont rien il était déjà là
alala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]